[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing neville longbottom
a magical artifact known as a remembral
and
chapter 9 of the philosopher's stone the
midnight
jewel more specifically we're going to
be diving in to what exactly a remembral
is as well as neville's relationship
with his own
remembral for those unaware a remembral
is a large
magical marble-sized glass ball that
contains
smoke the function of a remembral is in
the name
as it serves as an indicator of whether
or not you have forgotten
something it fills with red smoke when
the owner has forgotten something
otherwise it's clear it also turns clear
if the thing that was forgotten is
remembered they are somewhat readily
available for purchase in the wizarding
world and they make the perfect gift for
your absent-minded friends
now who do we know that's calamitous and
forgetful
why young neville longbottom of course
neville
actually received one as a gift from his
gran at the beginning of the 1991-1992
school year
neville's remembral as it happens is
actually the reason that harry got the
position of zika
on the gryffindor quidditch team during
their first flying lesson in madame
hooch's class
neville injures himself and leaves his
remembral behind
malfoy spots it immediately look
it's that stupid thing longbottom's
grand sent him
give that here malfoy i think i'll leave
it somewhere for longbottom to find
how about up a tree give it here
come and get it potter after draco took
the remembral
he threw it high up into the air
thinking that it would land on the
ground somewhere nearby
and smash into a thousand pieces but boy
was he wrong
as harry potter took this opportunity to
flex his flying skills
and save the remember from being broken
mcgonagall who saw the whole scenario
transpire
was immediately convinced that harry
would make an excellent seeker
for the gryffindor quidditch team in
chapter 9 of the philosopher's stone
neville explains the rememberable it's a
remembral
he explained grand noser forget things
this tells you if there's something
you've forgotten to do
look you hold it tight like this and if
it turns red
oh his face fell because the remembral
had suddenly glowed scarlet
you've forgotten something now that you
know what a remembral
is the next important question is what
did neville forget
it's never actually revealed in the book
or the film
which coincidentally suggests different
things what neville forgot
but we do have enough information to
make some theories
in the book i think that it's most
likely that neville forgot the password
to the gryffindor tower
later on in the same chapter that the
remembral is mentioned
harry ron and hermione find neville
outside the tower
when he bumps into them he explains that
he'd forgotten the password
thank goodness you found me i've been
out here for hours
i couldn't remember the new password to
get into bed
the remembral was likely trying to
remind him about the new password
but neville forgot however the film has
a different answer to this question
if we go by the events of the film the
most obvious answer is that neville
forgot to put on his robe
we can make this assumption because in
the scenes that contain the remembral
he is the only student not wearing a
robe did you guys ever wonder what it
was that neville forgot
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you